coming up next week in Brussels and no
summer holiday hangover for the
Parliament as mepz get back to work with
hearings on the emission testing scandal
discuss next steps for the EU visa visa
brexit and financing the european
project welcome to the agenda a former
commissioner has albeit indirectly lay
the blame on car manufacturers but now
as a more and more members old the
former barroso commission take the floor
of the investigative committee will any
PS now lay the blame at their door
former European Commissioner for
enterprise from industry Gunther von
Hagen said this week at the emission
measurements in the automotive sector or
ms committee the EU laws were clear on
rules for different devices are
disregarded by manufacturers any PS will
now talk to the former environment
commissioner yanez for touch Nick and
the former Commission vice president
antonietta Yanni responsible for
industry money makes the world go round
and in the case the European Union it
need quite a bit of it so finding ways
to finance itself are hugely important
overdue days emmy peas and members of
national parliament have great how to
put and resources to better use better
integration and cooperation of EU and
national budgets opening and closing
statements will be made by EP president
martin shots and a commission president
luca and now for the news in brief to
vote will take place at the civil
liberties committee on visa
liberalisation for potential EU members
georgia and kosovo on monday creative
europe is the european commission's
almost 1.5 billing you a program to help
creative in audio-visual sectors members
of the culture committee will discuss a
study on the impact the program so far
and will then consider launching their
own report which would contain
recommendations to the commission on
monday the constitutional committee
votes to renew the membership of three
members of the court of Auditors the
result the UK referendum
unexpected and the consequences are
still not quite clear the word
potentially does the EU and the UK stand
on brexit on Monday the Constitutional
Affairs Committee will delve into big
questions and hurdles ahead of the
soon-to-be 27 member states lock and
that's all we have this agenda take care
and enjoy the week